[Music]
hello and welcome to our expert webinar
product development focus automation
intelligence and simplicity
with our guest christie sofat group vice
president of oracle customer experience
marketing
in conversation with anon naranjan our
chief product officer here at simply
learn
we will be doing several polls during
the webinar
here's the first one just briefly how
much
work experience do you have we'll give
shristian
an idea of who's in our audience and
also how are you doing today
um are you feeling well
okay or a little under the weather
and our results show that um we have a
very experienced audience today
and we also have everybody uh
feeling pretty well except for one or
two people i hope that you will feel
better after
you hear what trishi and nana have to
say uh with that i'm going to
introduce anonym who is
the chief product officer of simply
learn
and allow him to introduce trishti
thank you stuart i appreciate you giving
me the mic i wanted to welcome all our
you know users here and audience here
who have come from linkedin youtube
or directly through the link that you
received welcome to this
forum um very excited to see the level
of experience that we have in front of
us and also
you know really excited to see the
number of participants here uh
quite a good turnout so thank you for
being here today we're going to have it
very casual we're going to have a good
conversation and look forward to seeing
the questions that come to us
and we do have a very special guest
today and trisha by the way is a group
vice president at oracle
and she manages customer experience
marketing has a lot of experience
in building scaling world-class internet
consumer and sas enterprise products
and she provides strategic technical
operational leadership to a global
organization
and has built up this culture product
innovation and execution there
she has been solving literally every
problem that's possible in the product
domain or marketing domain if you think
about it
marketing automation personalization
loyalty mobile mark tech
consumer search you name it right and
for someone at her level
she has a track record of hiring a
players building strong team
and leading geographically distributed
teams as well uh she has done a
bachelor's of engineering
in computer science from nit soros and
is an mba from the university of
washington
so swissy a really big welcome to you
and
uh really good to have you here hello
and hello everybody um good evening uh
and good morning
based on which geography you're in um
maybe afterward also
if somebody's in london but um
uh very glad to be here and looking
forward to having this conversation
definitely passionate about
the subject so looking forward to having
a good conversation with you on advances
wonderful interesting i'm going to ask a
question straight away which is going to
be sort of
what i consider a dumb question but i
think it's important this topic is about
automation intelligence to create great
customer experiences right
and you know the question first of all
that comes out why is this relevant why
is this important
why does this matter maybe you can set
up sort of a ground you know reality for
us and then we'll get into the real meat
of it
right i mean i think you know today and
you know this is a special year for all
of us
i think it's been uh you know technology
is mainstream
uh just based on the fact that all of us
have been you know um
sort of stuck in at home and doing a lot
of things which technology has been
enabler
but having said that you know i think uh
really
you know the world is changing right uh
i mean today you kind of have
uh you know like in a world of 7 billion
like five billion people have cell
phones
right you you kind of have internet as
important as electricity right you uh
you kind of have 5g here
right you can have i think it's 1.5
billion
sorry trillion photographs digital
footprint out there so i mean it's just
you know all of this is out there all
the business consumers
are using you know whether it's the
iphone or a smartphone we're using it
many of us are using the alexa
we're you know using swiggy or
netflix or uber again you know you're
kind of using all of this
and what is very clear is that uh
simplicity is becoming very important
you know i mean you know you all look at
iphone
uh you know we all want to use the
product which is easy to use which
is good to uh you know have a great
design whether you look at alexa and be
able to have a conversation with the
machine
that's becoming normal right so we are
surrounded by technology
and we are able to consume it today
pretty much like we used to turn on the
television
right so the complexity of the software
uh has to start getting hidden more and
more and we see that and i think this is
very very relevant for
product uh people who are building
products in this age
right so if you uh are not aware of all
these basic tenants that
simplicity is the key for the consumer
and behind the scenes the technology is
powering that whether it's through
intelligence and automation and we can
talk a lot more about that
but i think you know i think i think we
as we have you know keep swapping places
we as the viewers
and we as the people behind the scenes
and and you know figure that out that's
really
you know that's where this is headed uh
so i that's that's why i thought this
was uh
probably a relevant conversation for
this feeling absolutely i think you know
especially some
some people call it digital disruption
some people call it digital
transformation
you know these are all really big words
right and we're going to get into the
meat of that in a few minutes but
you know you started talking about it a
little bit into the why
but if you think of the consumer's
expectation from digital disruption
digital transformation
what do you think are the new
expectations that the folks have from
what the new reality is right yeah see
when i look at digital transformation
now you know
for a minute going back to what a
company thinks of it and then you know
at one level in the consumer consume is
it right i mean we really
think of it as back office and front
office right so if you think about you
know back
office being your payroll processing
your procurement so if you're if you're
in industry you're doing all of that in
the back office in that scenario the
customer is
you know not seeing it it's happening
behind the scenes now when you come to
cx
we are talking about the experience of
you know what is the front office which
is that means how the customer interacts
with you
what is that digital transformation
right so that's really to me the
definition of
you know customer experience so i i
think really
customers uh what we want as customers
from the brands that we
are working with is you know today when
we talk about digital transformation i
think it's about
how we discover the brand how we engage
with the brand
how we consume the services of the brand
and how they provide
service to us i think these four tenants
are the key pillars of digital
transformation right so
uh you know and we can go more into
examples right i mean in the sense you
know do you have an online presence can
i even find you there
how do you reach out to me yeah you know
what is your marketing is it
personalized is it not you know how are
you
how are you engaging with me is is my
experience easy right today we all are
you know i'm using uh
google pay quite a bit even when i go to
the common park or
for a run in the morning i can you know
buy a little juice with google play
right so i can just
run with my phone uh so it's the ease of
use to consume and transact right
it's the service it's the return policy
it doesn't matter right
so i mean i think it is it is about
transforming
all of those and i think that's really
what the customer
experience is all about you know can you
change those touch points um wonderfully
said
take the complexity make it easier for
the user that's really what this is all
about
right now i'm going to turn to the
audience a little bit i have a question
for you all and i think stuart is going
to put the
you know poll hopefully on on our forum
here
um i'm very curious we have a lot of
people who are pretty senior some people
who are a little more early in a career
in terms of your involvement in a
digital disruption or digital
transformation project
directly or indirectly i'm very curious
how many of us all
have you know it see this as a priority
right now for your company at this point
of time
love to hear a yes or no and of course
it's a bit of a plug question
this is an audience that's come for this
topic so i'm assuming there's a lot of
yeses here
let's see who surprised us
[Laughter]
the answer should still come at the end
so we'll give it a few more seconds
all right wonderful we'll give it a few
seconds
all right here chevy uh take the answers
and look at what came back
wonderful and i think you know this is
pretty like i said it's a question
uh you're all here to understand you
know what does digital instruction
really mean
how do you improve customer experience
so it absolutely makes sense so we're
going to get into the meat of the
conversation now
you know i think you know one thing that
especially you talked about is that the
product is starting to get more in the
customer experience right
um how has the focus on how a product
works
um you know how is it shifted towards
more of a customer experience i think
you started talking about the back
office
front office analogy right but when you
look at the products that you've been
part of the experiences that you've been
part of how is that balance shifted in
your mind
yeah i mean i think you know again
because our focus is customer experience
we are really talking
about the front office right where a
customer is interacting with a brand and
i think
that uh we have moved away even in
the digital products that we are
building today for it to be
your functionality to an experience
right i mean you've already seen that
in consumer products right i mean you
the iphone is the example right i mean
it's not about making a call it's not
just about that there is a bunch of
things about
owning an iphone right which is sort of
a consumer product if you will
i think the same you know you you travel
in an airline right i mean the
functionality is going from a to b
or a car it's going from point a to b
but it's not just about
can this thing take me from point a to b
right it is
about the experience right whatever
that is defined in a car talk about
travel we have the taxi and then you
have the uber
right uh functionality is the same you
can go from point a to b
however what is the experience right are
you able to
get it when you want it are you able to
customize the music when you're sitting
in it
you know somebody greeting you best
friend whatever it is right
so so i i think it's the same analogy
right that we all are trying to do
as we build products uh which are you
know
sort of completely digital major whether
it's an e-commerce site it's your brand
whatever it is right it is no longer
about
uh can i do a transaction and buy a book
from your website
right it's not about that it is about
the whole experience around are you
suggesting which book i can read
are you do you know me right
so so i think anywhere we look the
consumer expectation
is really now about experience i think
there's no going back
we are only going forward and it's
getting more and more interesting
uh the space has a lot of innovation
right i mean
you know it's getting more and more
creative if you will right and the other
side is that you know you
are probably dead if you're not uh
you're doing this as an example
today if i uh if i if i get a promotion
email you know that for this assignment
which is men's clothes you know i might
have a bad experience with that brand
i'll be like listen i'm not even
shopping in this brand you know what i
mean i might walk away with
from the brand right i mean we've done
research which says that you know
one third of the consumers because you
know the literature of choices
will walk away from a brand with a bad
experience right so
not only is it important sort of to keep
your customers
uh and retain them but you know you may
use them completely if you are not
focused on customer experience
at just your functionality uh that
doesn't make sense
absolutely makes sense and i think you
know especially as i was thinking about
it makes a lot of sense but i also found
it very funny um
when you talk about the car experience i
just realized um i'm probably pretty
unique i drive a
marathi wagon r it's the one place where
experience actually is one of the things
that i actually compromise
but i totally get the idea highly
personalized experience at scale that's
really what it is
but you know especially the question
that becomes creating this highly
personalized experience
is that really possible i mean right now
these you know internet products they
cater to
thousands and millions sometimes even
billions of people right
so is this just a pipe dream or this is
just actually achievable this is
something that can happen
so i'd like to hear uh how you think
about that
yeah i mean i think see the and that's
where you know um
we get into you know the whole
intelligence and automation and portion
of it right
uh and i think uh ultimately we were in
a world of
batch and blast right like one size fits
all
you started doing some basic
segmentation you know you're like okay
man woman people live here
you know you know five things about a
person you can you know do a
one is to end kind of a model right like
okay like this
this particular segment uh but as
the amount of data that you have about
an individual increase
as you now have technology which can
us you know pretty much scrunch and you
know
uh run algorithms on that data do some
predictive stuff
uh that's what is now giving you the
power to do
a one is to one sort of an experience i
mean think about
let's take a simple example you may go
to a website i'm in google perspective
maybe even simply learn right and i'm
sure you're doing some of it already
right
uh if you know what i have been
searching for google
and you have details of you know what
emails i have opened
you have some digital footprint data of
mine
the kind of programs that i will see on
that
website might be very unique to me
yeah i mean is it is it i mean the more
you know about me the more unique it can
be
and and more likely is the fact that i
will
be interested in the product right so i
i think this is not
magic but it is a magic sauce
right and all of us are in the
technology uh field
and really the magic sauce is a
combination
of um ai
automation which then gives that you
know personalization and
and you know and then the experience has
become consistent relevant
uh and you know simplified for the user
right so that that's that's really what
it is all right
so i think you mentioned two terms i
think uh you know especially that i
think are pretty relevant i'd like to
get a little deeper here
you talked about simplified automation
and you also talked about orchestration
right um can you give me a little bit
can you give the audience a little more
of a depth of understanding of what
those terms really mean because i'll
tell you a lot of folks here
are from a product background and
they'll be thinking of these two terms
and saying look it kind of makes sense
but maybe not right
so can you go a little deeper on that
right yeah i mean again you know these
are english terms and we can use them
how we want but i'll
i'll tell you uh the way i'm thinking
about this space right
um and and you know let's let's go back
to the example where we spoke about
segmentation and things like that right
so i
i think that you know and if i can just
even go to like the products that i work
on you know which is sort of a marketing
automation uh tool right
uh as an example so if you if you look
at that what you could do is
let's let's go back five six years you
know an automation is some a tool which
lets you do something which you don't
have to do manually right
so let's say you want to send a message
to someone
you want to create a segment you want to
come up with a message
and then you want to send it right i
mean those are the three basic steps
that you want to do
it was automated you don't have to hand
type the email addresses you know there
is some tools which can help you to
create the list
you will get a letter where you can type
the email and you can schedule it
and it'll send it right at 9am now
that's sort of an automation now
how do you simplify this experience
uh for this person doing this job let's
just take that as an example right
today uh you know now you have the power
of intelligence right
so can you uh can you instead of this
person trying to do this workflow
can you make this very prescriptive and
can you make this very guided
can you say that this person says that
you know my real goal is just to
reach 1000 people would be very
interested and get like you know what 20
click-through rates or whatever just
some strategy right and then can you
auto-generate an audience but it's one
thing for the person to say
you know if this is your strategy this
is your right audience
right uh if this is your audience based
on historical data we know that the
best time to send them will decide you
don't you don't schedule it at 9am
because you know somebody's a 9 a.m
person somebody's a 10am person
somebody is a midnight person right so
let's make sure that the system
uh is simplifying it for you and
automating when to send this message
right let's say you have to be you have
to think about what should the message
be should i say best offer should i use
this word
what will attract people what is the
system gives you
the content right and predicts it right
so my point is that intelligence
in every you know this is a simple
workflow right you're trying to
message some people it's a three-step
process you can sort of extend this to
anything right i mean you can extend
this to
doing an expense you uh system you can
extend this to writing
you know any software doing an
e-commerce transaction but
can you automate this right and simplify
the experience so very simplified
automation really is
keeping the consumer in mind to simplify
the workflow for them
what all can technology do for you now
intelligence right so so that's where
that comes in or at least
that's the way i'm using it in this
context absolutely and i think
especially one big takeaway also is
you're looking at intelligence as
machine intelligence in a lot of ways
more than human intelligence so i think
the scale factor comes through machine
intelligence
now you know one aspect that i think i'm
very curious about i mean you're talking
about machine intelligence orchestration
now you need to know a lot about your
users you need to have a lot of data
right
so to be able to really get this right
how does the data aspect of it and data
signal from consumers
shape this experience right and i think
this is a question that actually one of
the
audience members has asked as well right
how does that data signal and the
consumer data come in how does that play
into those automation and orchestration
yeah yeah so i mean you know let me just
very quickly touch on orchestration so i
mean i think that was simplified
automation and from an orchestration
respect the only thing i would add is
the real-time nature
right so i mean i think there is one
thing which is the flow and then there
is the
you know we you know people are nobody
wants every
you know we are living you know like i
said started out with everybody has a
phone right
everything is in the moment now you know
you can't send somebody something which
is outdated right so as you get the
real-time aspect
you can orchestrate things in the right
channel for people
whether they you know to email phone
mobile
at the right time uh that that would
just you know time the orchestration
portion
now coming back to you know how i mean
data is sort of the basic ingredient
here right i mean there is moving around
that
uh and and ultimately that's what helps
you bring the intelligence right so i
mean i think
um i mean ultimately any algorithm needs
historical data
right uh it needs real-time data
and then it uses those two to predict
right that's how this technology works
right i mean that's like the 101 or
whatever of uh what is uh
uh you know machine learning so uh so in
terms of that
uh because it's really data driven right
i mean we all we all understand that we
write programs that we all
you know grow up writing programs we
didn't write programs
in this way where the program learns
based
on historical data and and the real-time
data and predicts right so it's it's
really a database
a data construct the whole data science
intelligence is
highly dependent on data so uh so so
definitely that
uh that's what is the key enabler i know
right i mean
there is no way around that right and
and the fact that we all are
internet we all are on our phones uh
giving that little of data to our brand
right they can use that to do this hyper
personalization for us right it's a give
and take
now if you are one of those consumers
who say you know and then people are
going on both sides today right um
that i don't want to share nothing uh
then clearly the brand will know nothing
about you
and it's very difficult for them to get
hyper personalized personalized uric
absolutely
right but but if you are uh sort of
giving some signals
that's what will be leveraged to
personalize your experience right
absolutely i'm going to go a little bit
to the side from you know
so the topic i think one question that
from the audience is coming i think it's
quite an interesting question i'd like
to hear your opinion on it
um of course machine intelligence can
scale can create personalization a much
larger scale than a human could scale
right one of the questions that comes is
that
is there an output here where machine
intelligence goes without bound
there's no human intervention at all um
what's your thought on that
yeah i mean you know all of us are right
now you know living in this world that
what'll happen you know
but it's 23 years ago it's possible
right yeah
i mean it's possible but you know the
important thing is around data quality
right so so the point that today we are
not yet there
that the systems can totally figure out
the noise
and the noise can uh you know
change the algorithm uh completely but
you know look at auto driving cars right
i mean it is reading the signals but you
still have issues right so it's only
getting better right i mean you're
reading the signals and making a
prediction
i mean that's how it is right yeah all
right it's real-time data which you're
in real time able to process because you
now have that high level technology that
you you know
you were predicting something and
something came in real time can you
change
right so all of that is you know you're
seeing that it's possible already right
but it's really about the human touch
in some cases things are not black and
white
something in some products it is about
the sentiment
it is about the human touch so it's
those aspects which probably have to get
modulated a little bit uh and maybe
these algorithms will learn that
soon too as we input enough data around
that
but but it's uh you know technology-wise
it's possible
if you will right uh just technically
speaking if you will
yeah but we're not we're not at that
point at this point you're not at the
point because we don't have that sort of
set of data
today which we can totally run by uh
for a lot of the industry right for
somebody models
getting better makes a lot of sense so i
think we'll get into a little bit of the
technology aspects of this as well i
think what you know so far you've heard
is
there's a lot of in data that's required
to make this hyper personalization scale
possible
there's some level of intelligent
automation that uses the data and
figures out what happens
and then this orchestration at scale
which really takes that automation and
applies it to whatever channel
or whatever scale you have to apply it
to right for someone who's here and
thinking about look i want to get to
that place where i start doing hyper
personalization
but i don't know where to start what
technologies should i worry about what
technology capabilities do i need to
build out can you give us all a little
bit of a sense of
where do we start what are the
technology enablers what are the
capabilities we need to build out
yeah i mean i think that you know uh
ultimately and i think a lot of people
uh are probably thinking of it but maybe
not completely in a structured manner i
mean i think ultimately a
customer 360 and as much as you can
populate that
would make sense right it doesn't matter
what your business is uh right uh
uh you know so i mean that would be sort
of one way to think about
if you want to go into this journey of
understanding your customer completely
and giving them this type of
personalized experience
right because like we discussed data is
the core so thinking of each of your
customer
and filling in as much data around that
customer
centralizing that system uh you know all
of that is also technological challenge
right that that could be one way to
think about it
from uh sort of you know how do i build
up right uh in terms of you know and
then just depends on the business you
can throw up
in terms of uh and you know it's just
not about technology it is truly and we
all know that but it is about
building the customer empathy right and
kind of thinking about
the customer first right so what is
their experience so it is around that
mindset
which is super critical right i mean you
have to have the customer mindset
and then you have the technology and the
data and then you sort of think about
the experience right whether you do a
design thinking
uh you know walk through or however you
know every organization has their own
favorite method of doing this
but ultimately keeping the custom pencil
what is the journey that you want to
uh presents right and then use
technology for that
uh i mean that that would be a way to uh
go ahead and build it and i and i mean i
think today's digital transformation and
developer
and i mean i think you know whether we
talk about you need power and you know
we all are using cloud i mean
you know because we need the auto scale
if you want to have a lot of data so you
know it's the usual right i mean
we need the we need the large machines
we need the whole big data
to you know start the whole thing right
and and then we need that data
for our customers and let's use you know
a stack which helps us enabling you know
the experience that we want for our
customers
right i mean that would be a weight it
understood so i think you know somebody
who's aspiring to become
you know use these kind of capabilities
right you're looking at data scientist
products managers designers
i think you know at a very high level
you're thinking about first of all the
customer empathy the design thinking is
part of it
um and then there are specific skills
they probably have to learn right are
there
you know any specific areas that you
would suggest are pretty relevant common
themes and skills that you would
recommend for these kind of roles which
are going to be at the sort of cutting
edge of these kind of experiences right
building these kind of experiences
yeah i mean i think you know when i look
at um data science and i feel that you
know
it's not uh it's sort of like an
intersection if you think of it as a
venn diagram right
of around domain expertise right i mean
you kind of have to have the domain
in whichever field it is right uh then
there is definitely some level of you
know
math with the whole stats and then this
computer science right i mean it's sort
of at the intersection of it you know
you can't
you can't just be your sign and not know
anything about the domain right let's
say you want to go fraud detection
so you know whatever it is right and you
kind of have to understand the domain a
little bit and then you don't need to
understand that so i mean i think
i mean i think that's true if you want
to get into the data science
scheme right i mean as a product manager
if you will right so there is
you know it depends on where you are
right because ultimately
as a product manager it's really about
looking at the current journeys
and thinking about how this can be
simplified
i think that's why i bring the whole so
then you're not going to think
intelligence in a vacuum
right intelligence is a means for a
customer experience right so you know so
i mean i think it's really about
thinking about a certified customer user
experience right you have to start from
there
if you are sort of on the product
management side or you're defining
sort of product definition and the
technology partners of yours right
who are hopefully building you know like
us
are going to leverage the technology
right and are going to leverage through
your data science and say listen do you
have all of this data
to to give this simplified experience at
the abc
data right i mean like let's take an
example of we
spoke about uh send time optimization
right so let's not send a message to
everybody
at 9am let's send it to them when they
open right so if somebody said that
that you know somebody has to think
about that the data scientist
is going to solve the problem by saying
okay let's collect the current pattern
of open
open times let's lay it out on 24 hours
let's see the peaks and then let's
predict and you know now one day
i'm will take one days of data 15 days
is good enough and then
make it rolling maybe there's
seasonality
whatever right that's that's why you
need the maps and the
you know computer science but to come up
with the idea
that let's think about an experience
which is simplified
uh is is really a basic product
management
sort of thought process but sort of
thinking of it i would say more for
productive
guided fashion because knowing that our
consumers want things simple
right uh is is one way uh to think about
it
got it and i think uh you know
especially we're gonna go a little off
script a little bit if you may i think
there's some great questions that are
being asked
by the audience and i think we'll keep
it open even i'll give my views on some
of these things from a different
perspective with me right
two very related topics one which vishal
is asking is
having automation does that dilute the
human touch
and a very related question that came
from suthi is you know she's part of a
bank and they've actually automated the
entire process
made it brought it online and customers
are looking at look i want that human
touch
this is not working for me so there's an
interesting tension here
between you know simplification through
online models
and you know the human touch potentially
which could be at odds here
any opinions on that topic yeah see i
mean i
like i said right we are in transition
we are not there yet right uh but let's
let's look at the banks and i you know i
exactly don't know what use is but you
know i
look at a chatbot experience which is a
great example of
automation and intelligence right
now we all have had our experiences
where you know the chatbot
goes if you go off script if you will it
it can really
go crazy right uh or you know you will
not get what you want and you
you want the human touch right so today
we you know we run an integrated model
right as in at some point the chatbot
will maybe pull in a human if it can't
help you right
uh but many of the things are just very
easily done with the chatbot
right and i don't have to wait for hours
so
am i uh i would you know i would never
call
a system if i knew that i had to wait
for two hours the fact that the time
to answer is becoming really short i
like the automated system now
there is a fallback because today you
know we don't have all the data points
right and the banking systems are new
they don't have all the questions
asked in the chat what the chatbot
hasn't learned there isn't enough data
right for it to know all the backups uh
you know your alexa can
you know play all the songs but you know
maybe doesn't know all the accents right
so
ultimately the more we use these systems
the more data they have the better
they'll get
again like i said there's no magic but
there is a magic sauce
right and the sauce needs more
ingredients right
so so really as we use these tools
the automation will get better uh we
need to come up with mechanisms to back
it up within the touch
in this example of the chatbot which
could be a bank use case or not
uh but you know as a technologist
uh you know i am quite bullish on
on uh on intelligence and automation and
and i think that you know it basically
you know moves
you know it's not like people do have
nothing to do right it moves what you're
doing
right i mean we start imagine we are we
are you know we keep imagining more
creative things
so it's you know we don't even know
where we'll be headed so it's not about
you know um it's about just like you
know moving up the chain in my mind
right
uh that's the way i do and especially
i'm going to take one
element of what you just said and
actually maybe expound on that a little
bit i think what you said is
as long as that experience being built
actually does better than what the human
touch was able to bring
and make it a lot more personalized you
you have one right with technology and
it's in simplification
and you know just a personal experience
from my uh side you know when covert
hit right edtech before edtech was a
different world
and post you know postcovid was a
different world for ethics and
we found that the acceptance of online
training i think there's a significant
spike in how that changed very quickly
and sometimes it's all the mindsets that
have to change so just to see specific
examples sometimes it's also about the
mindset of the
customer and you've got to kind of get
it technology where it actually is
relevant and when it is relevant as well
so i think that's another fair point
there
another question that's being asked is
you know um
if you look at the data that's actually
used to really customize and personalize
we start getting into pretty interesting
places where
data privacy and things like that happen
i think you addressed this during the
conversation
uh but i'd love to hear a little bit of
thought there because i think there were
a couple of questions
on that aspect yeah i mean i think i
think you know
uh it is you know i think i think it is
you know we're going on two extremes on
this right i mean like i said firstly
like if you
are wanting that personalized experience
there's no way around
to share data but again there is no one
rule for everyone right i mean we do
understand that
you know data you know we've had enough
issues security is super important right
that's why
you know there's a whole industry around
security and encryption
and how can we protect the data when it
exists where it exists right
uh so but but i mean my view is that it
is a personal choice
right and today as technology companies
we you know we cannot we need to keep
privacy uh you know it should be a
customer choice
privacy needs to be implemented
completely uh security is
is something that you know we need to be
responsible about as
uh product developers right i mean
security needs to be a core tenant of
development right so
privacy is a choice for the customers
and if they choose to say i want to be
private forget me and whatever it is
then we need to do that
all right and respect that um and uh and
we need to make sure our systems are
secure
right i mean as software um enablers if
a system is not secure less people will
give you know
say yes to you know let me give you my
data right
uh we also see the whole gen x the ny
gen z i know what what is the
terminology now i mean the younger
generation
my daughter who's 12 my son who's 16
right i mean uh
they are you know uh they are technology
they
you know they the hesitation is less
right uh
you know so so you don't know where it's
headed right so it is it is a
responsibility at least to make sure
it's secure
independent of privacy privacy is super
critical as well
uh and it needs to be come from a child
so that's wonderful
and maybe just to you know go back to a
couple of questions back like we talked
about uh you know the capabilities of
skills we'd like to
have to really get the simplicity and
personalization skills happening
we have a poll for the you know for the
audience today i'd like to hear
and understand what level of
preparedness you have in terms of some
of these domain skills we talked about
design thinking customer empathy and
some of these hard skills skills
uh so still if you don't mind let's get
the poll out there i'd like to see how
people see
the uh fair in terms of a scale of one
to five for some of these uh
strong skills that are required as a
basis for
personalization at scale of course there
are a lot of skills
so please do read through this and then
the answer is pretty simple rate one to
five
uh in terms of where you stand and again
i'll just read through
the skills we have on the screen we're
curious to know if you look at the
list of skills there how would you rate
yourself in others getting started
five expert i actually advise other
people now especially would be a five
so just let's be very clear and while
we're waiting there was a question on
you know where should we start the
journey i think that was a question that
came up in the q a
some of these skills you're seeing on
the screen would be great places to
start
right and so um you know fundamentally
it's your choice i think christie said
it really well there's an automation
domain
there's a data domain there's an
orchestration side there's a customer
empathy and design thinking side
that comes down to which role you choose
and which area you go into right so i
think
this is i think the question that
answers that question to some extent we
are done um
and the way the poll is answered is uh
people entered in a number so
it's not really going to display you a
survey with the result but
how do you know the result
all right i have to assume that with any
uh statistical distribution you've got
an average and
you've got the outliers so i have to i
have to assume that there are a few
threes fours and five zeros
probably a lot of ones and twos here but
again you know the whole idea of this
was to give you a little bit of a broad
view of what i think needs to be uh
picked up and then the journey is yours
to take personally right
uh especially back to you i want to
thank you so much for your time today
it was an absolute pleasure having a
conversation and hearing your thoughts
on this
and honestly there are not a lot of
brands out there and a lot of leaders
there who have this kind of clarity of
thought
on this kind of very advanced topic so
really appreciate your sharing your
views today right thank you it was a
pleasure and
uh wishing wishing the audience all the
best in whatever
thoughts we decide to take all right
thank you absolutely
thank you thank you stuart thank you
um and we will do one last
oops one last poll here to ask
our audience
what are you looking forward to learning
yeah
various skills um things that were
discussed
or touched on in today's
webinar and you can see that
data science ai machine learning
are popular so our product and project
management and
rpi our rpa rather so
we'll be able to follow up with you
you can contact us at ask us at
simplylearn
to learn more about these different
topics i want to thank
shrishti and anand here is
trishy's linkedin contact information if
you'd like to
reach out to her and i'd also like to
mention our skill up program
which gives access
to over 300 in demand skills in various
technology areas
and this is a free program gives you
access to
our video content and lets you
essentially preview
our certification courses so
you i'll put a link for that into the
chat
box right here
and i'd like to also invite you
to join our next webinar one week from
tonight
wednesday march 31st is a marketing
digital marketing webinar storytelling
with marketing analytics with matt
bailey the president of sitelogic
and he'll discuss how to communicate
what your marketing analytics tell you
to your peers your colleagues your
bosses in ways that they can
access and understand and again i will
put a link into the chat box for that
that concludes our webinar today
please do contact us through our social
channels on facebook
twitter and linkedin love to hear from
you and keep in touch with you
and thank you all for being here today